i lost listen i'll tell my number should
i tell my numbers right now or no i'll
tell them i don't care i love you guys
um
when i ended this show and i started
raven baxter raven's home i was 210
pounds
i am now 170. raven simone reveals her
40 pound weight loss during her return
to the view it feels good to be able to
share a little bit more of my life to
the world
on thursday the 36 year old former view
co-host stopped by her old stomping
grounds with her wife miranda and when
asked about her health journey she
credited her lady love whom she married
in 2020 for inspiring her to shed the
lbs what made me want to change was her
actually
i want to be here for her as long as i
can and i found out some numbers at the
doctor that were not pleasant for
someone in my age bracket or any age
bracket to be honest with you the ravens
home star said that with an assist from
her wife she was able to make some big
changes to her diet with her help and
guidance and love and fantastic cooking
skills which everyone here knows
she
helped me kick sugar and i say kick
sugar because it is an addictive drug
and i was addicted to it in wheat form
in regular form and it's out of my
system now raven says she eats whole
foods and also practices intermittent
fasting but noted that she doesn't
exercise as for indulging her sweet
tooth she snacks on keto-friendly
cookies and when eti caught up with
raven last month she said that her
former cheetah girl star who's now on
raven's home adrian houghton helps keep
her accountable we're on a little bit of
a health journey together we're on a
mission for each other we send each
other our food picks and while fans
loved seeing raven who hosted the view
from 2015 to 2016 back on the panel
don't get too used to it last year the
actress and her wife started their own
youtube channel and during a chat with
et she explained why she prefers the
platform over daytime tv and what i love
about youtube and what i love about what
we're doing together is
yes we don't have a
whole entire sound stage with an
audience and a lighting crew and red
cameras and 14 setups and a producer
we're able to talk about topics without
influences of a daytime producer saying
okay i need you to have this point of
view and fight i've been in the industry
for the past 34 years i know what it
feels like to be produced i know what it
feels like to not really have control of
your brand because you've hired many
people to help you with it and it's
funny because we started it we didn't
ask my manager we didn't ask anything we
just started it and everybody was like
oh my goodness oh my goodness and i'm
like listen
people ask am i going to go back on a
panel people ask what's your next
adventure and the next adventure is
letting you into our life the way we
want you into our life you're not going
to see me in a pair of heels in a
push-up bra and a girdle like i'm in
here no makeup no we talking about real
topics the check is different and it's
not always about the money
[Music]